I can't believe that this is happening
and this and this and this too yes games
and virtual worlds are about to get a
heck of a lot better in terms of visual
quality so what just happened first this
paper took nerves to the next level what
are nerves well nerves are neural
Radiance Fields a tool for us to create
photos or video footage of something in
the real world and then make a copy of
it as a virtual world that we can play
in but through an amazing paper called
instant neurographics we can do this in
a matter of minutes often even seconds
so what's new here why write another
paper on it are we done here dear fellow
Scholars this is two minute papers with
Dr carah the answer is nope no sir we
are not even close to being done you see
the speed is satisfactory with instant
neurographics but the quality H not so
much look and here is the new technique
wow look at the hair the hair is now not
a blurry blob but it is a crisp piece of
geometry loving it so this new technique
finally gives us higher quality Virtual
Worlds worlds that are worth playing in
so high quality what does that mean
being slower that's what it means well
most of the time yes but does it also
mean this is slow too let's have a look
and oh my goodness are you seeing what I
am seeing this is easily twice as fast
as instant neurog graphics and at the
same time it is also of much higher
quality and it gets better now hold on
to your papers fellow scholar and look
in some cases it is up to 20x faster wow
that is absolutely incredible this kind
of improvement just one more paper down
the line I can hardly believe it yes
fellow Scholars this is the corner of
the internet where we look at research
papers Black Ink on a white table and
flip out together and did you notice it
have you found it look again these
scenes have tons of hairy things and
fabric and even more hair and then even
more hair wait a minute that dear fellow
Scholars is impossible nerves are not
good at modeling thin structures at all
right but this one is excellent how is
that even possible well here is where
shells come into the picture let's pop
the hood and oh yes first this technique
works very much like a nerve based
technique would but then here is where
the magic happens from a set of colorful
points in 3D space it constructs a shell
and from that shell we get a triangle
mesh oh boy are you thinking what I am
thinking oh yes using triangle meshes
means that we can use our amazing
computer graphics and physics simulation
algorithms to deform it yes so from now
on from your cameras we get not only a
virtual world that we can play in but we
can even run our physics simulations in
it I absolutely love this idea yummy but
wait this is AI research we are talking
about and oh my what is this can it be
that yes a separate specialized paper
for physics simulations within Nerf
based worlds is already available and
this one is a real treat we can simulate
elastodynamic motion within these words
and all this happens in real time and we
are still not done yet here is another
really cool Innovation on improving
neural Radiance Fields if these are
Virtual Worlds that means that we likely
wish to move around in them when we get
close to these objects the quality is
still not quite there from close by
however with this new technique we can
get closer and just zoom and zoom and
zoom and the quality is still there now
there is also a new different school of
thought for creating Virtual Worlds and
that happens through gaussian splatting
and this is a technique where you can
cheaply store a few of of these lamps
that we call gaussians but that's not
what you see on the screen what you see
here is a reconstruction of these lumps
which looks like this and this
representation also lends itself to
physics simulations this one is going to
be an absolute treat we can spread these
questionable materials on a piece of
virtual bread and my favorite even teet
oh yeah OG fellow colar remember this
legendary paper you might soon be able
to have this kind of quality with any
object in a virtual world that you
create by recording your own home or
anywhere on the planet wow this work
used to be a simulation paper that took
a long time to compute up to about 1
hour for every second of footage that
you see here for the baking paper and
fellow Scholars about 4 hours for every
second of footage here for the tearing
paper yes these are measured not in
frames per second but in seconds per
frame and we haven't even talked about
all the integral calculus and human
Ingenuity that is required for this yes
these were handcrafted techniques no AI
anywhere to be seen just the Ingenuity
of computer Graphics researchers and in
the future they might run in our Virtual
Worlds and video games in real time I
would absolutely love that I wanted to
make sure here that we honor the great
works out there and compare to them so
these four papers truly are a dream come
true for Virtual Worlds and as good
fellow Scholars we should always invoke
the first law of papers the first law of
papers says that research is a process
do not look at where we are look at
where we will be two more papers down
the line and just imagine what we will
be capable of two more papers down the
line my goodness if you have some ideas
let me know in the comments below what a
time to be alive if you're looking for
inexpensive Cloud gpus for AI Lambda now
offers the best prices in the world for
GPU Cloud compute no commitments or
negotiation required just sign up and
launch an instance and hold on to your
papers because with the Lambda GPU Cloud
you can now get on demand h100 instances
for just1 199 per hour yes 199 and they
are one of the first Cloud providers to
offer publicly available on demand h100
EXs did I mention they also offer
persistent storage so join researchers
at organizations like apple MIT and
ctech in using Lambda Cloud instances
workstations or servers make sure to go
to lamb.com
slapers to sign up for one of their
amazing GPU instances today